okay pitting new members thank you for
an outlet evening start by reading the
emergency evacuation output should we be
required to evacuate the building would
you please leave the building by the
nearest Plainville exit the respond fire
exit in this room if you need to
evacuate the room do so by the closed
door to the external fire escape
staircase please hold both have males in
place the stairs are wet or slippery if
anyone is unable to use the stairs that
they please at our others to exit the
room before they go to sleep I spoke
door where they can you give consistence
our assembly will be in the building ice
number one on the agenda apologies for
absence we have
[Music]
just for members capturing the municipal
here the review committee receives three
reports on the council's Treasury man
even function before the reports
opposition Council the three reports are
the key statement the mid-year review
and
this report for the media review comes
the period first of eight four twenty
nineteen to thirty just to briefly just
read through the report just highlight
any yes such as indicate this is the
mid-year report on the treasury
management and position for the council
and the report sets out an economic
update from our treasury managers link
and sets out their expectations in terms
of their future growth of the economy
and the interest rates they're
predicting over the next three years as
members will be one aware this and
plenty of fiscal uncertainty at the
moment so all forecasts you know it
slightly uncertain at this point in time
but they are forecasting that there will
be some rising interest rates and going
forward but obviously that year that
will be subject to the final outcome of
that brexit another and other political
changes over the next get burned a few
months in terms of the council's
position there are no policy changes to
our treasury management strategy which
was brought to this busy and febrile
Annan plan subsequently approved by both
Council in February of this year there
is no change to our potential indicators
position either there's a table within
the report that sets out our capital
expenditure forecast which obviously is
one of the drivers of our treasury
management and capital and strategy it
sets our original budget position and
then our front end of year forecast the
the main reason for the rise in capital
expenditure
between budgeted position and the
swimwear portion now is capital budgets
which were part of the 1819 capital
program which were unspent year-end and
then were subsequently approved by
executives bewell board into this year
of the program so yeah they've
previously been approved by executive
and are now incorporated into this
year's capital and capital program so
yeah we're forecasting at the moment to
spend three point three five million and
as members will be aware we don't
currently have any floor owing and we're
not projecting to well we haven't asked
to buy any monies in this financial year
it's our capital with financing
requirements very static from the start
of the year if there's any change to
that position in 1920 that would be
brought forward as part the treasury
management strategy proposals which are
people that this committee in February
of next year and so to move on to
Section six our investment portfolio I'm
probably best known for that this
financial year members to be able to see
that I'm on the table in Section six
point two that we started the year with
about twelve just over twelve million
pounds of investments and one eight
million and our current accounts since
that time we've placed investments of
nearly twenty eight million and we've
realized investments made 27 million so
there's a nest I will increase in our
the amount with house and investments of
just under 1 million pounds and there's
a decrease in our current account
balance of again just over 1 million
pounds so broadly speaking there's not a
massive difference between our overall
position at the start of the year in
terms of the net amount in our current
account and invest
and the position that we're reporting at
that at the mid-year that's just
basically summarized in the practical
and representational of that position
which is also showing within within the
report in terms of where we've got our
money's invested and young members will
be aware that in this trapping strategy
we sent out clearly parameters and
guidelines of where we can invest our
money as a council and we obviously have
our quite a low sort of risk profile as
a council when we choose to invest our
money in low-risk
but also relatively low return
investments so the table that's
explained call sets out when we've got
those investments at the moment so
they're split between some sometime
Darren Lloyd's accounts and also within
some money market funds so yes there's
to money more times where we've got
permits and bond money invested as well
the investment performance for the year
to date and it's cut out in the table at
six point five so this basically shows
what and our treasury management
advisors link would expect a sort of
average or normal return would be for
each sort of category of an investment
period and what the council's actually
achieved for the equivalent investments
it's made under each category and you
can see that we have outperformed the
average which means basically we're
getting the best return that we can on
the money we put invested for the type
of investments that we are allowed to
invest in under our current strategy so
I think we've got you know we were
fairly confident that we are achieving
the best returns we can within our
strategy as a result of that and as
partly as a result of that sort of
average length for investment increasing
slightly and the return that we're
expecting to make this year has
increased from eight thousand pounds
that we budgeted for which was maybe
slightly prudent and
we've already made 60,000 pounds almost
up from universe interest for the first
six months of the year and we're
projecting by a year own people that
made one hundred and thirty thousand
pounds so that may it will mean we've
made fifty thousand pounds
improvement in the interests that we
went compared to our budgeted position I
think that's the main points I would
draw your members attention to that as
ever if you've got any questions I'm
happy to try and answer
thank you very very quick one really
where you've got money market prime is
that a basket that investments or is it
just one bank is what they look like
easy and it's not a bank it is i yes i
fund which basically invest across tiny
called spectrum more than different
investments so that's why it's
classified ads with the lowest because
the it spreads the risk of spread so
widely but okay thank you very much
thank you where you show their capital
expenditure financing by as you say
we've brought forward under spans from
1890 these are quite substantial and
they're still not being spent parkway
clearly year what is a realistic
expectation of those being utilized by
the end of the financial year hmm yeah
so i think it's yeah good question and i
think we're probably unlikely to fully
spend our capital and budget this year
again which we've reported to executive
in our court to and financial reports so
that is something we are actively
reviewing ahead of their next the budget
for the next financial year to sort of
do a zero base review and make sure that
whatever we build into the capital
program going forward and is is achieved
it is achievable so yes i think this
probably will be someone who spends
again this year but i think we're
looking to challenge and not necessarily
roll those four it automatically which
perhaps has been the case in the past so
to make sure that we
she deliver on whatever we pay into the
program thank you thank you mr. chairman
because obviously the species of the air
quality chronic income it's a
substantial and if sighs it's a shame to
see it's not being spent the other
question I'd like to ask the officer and
I'm a bit concerned this isn't showing
that shot so perhaps you could increase
it include it before it goes to prom
cause we haven't sure the interest rates
that were achieving well six point four
you put who we're investing with how
long for
obviously the interest rate is quite
significant part of that decision could
that be shown and could you tell us what
it is actually at the moment so that
we're all aware of it so the the average
interest rate we are achieving is that's
out in the title beneath that's the
investment performance for the year
today it shows the average interest
rates of achieving across each category
of that's not the question I asked the
question I asked is how much interest
are we earning in each account santander
for example what is the interest rate
will not to pogchamp noice what is the
interest rate yeah so that's significant
okay yeah I can certainly take that way
and add it to the reports and I think
the interest rates do overseas and
particularly with the money market funds
will vary depending on the investor day
of the investment it's nice though it's
not a fix I'm interested right now so
but the other three are fixed interest
rate and do you know what they are I
don't have the nice ones offhand here
but as I say if we're going to take it
back to war council I'm not happy to
take that way and get the current rates
for you and then we can bring that back
thank you I've seen they're fixed and
they are usually fixed up but they point
in time but obviously they can yeah if
and for example their bank write those
up or down then the major banks usually
price ooh and then adjust their rates
accordingly but I think they probably
have been flat for the duration of the
first six months of the year because
there haven't been any changing the
interest rate from the bank
and the Central Bank of England thank
you Joe just really want to restate the
highlights of what Naomi said quite
pleased with how things are going there
but just focus again on the projected
interest rates on 6.3 there are
projected interest rates at the moment
and desert there's a general perception
based on a number of years experience
that the wlb rates are exceptionally low
they have been exceptionally low but you
can see the step up depending on the
length of time that you'd look to take
out and you can see the projection going
forward that those rates will rise so
for the wider audience of what the
council does it is worth bearing that
increase in mind
obviously on 5.2 with our capital
finance requirements there aren't any
verbs we recount sort of evolving
ambition and the Marquis of ambition
there at some stage in the future and
then finally finally just back on 26.6
where you've got the cap the table right
at the bottom where you've got the
council's performance and you've got the
benchmark return and I don't think that
does reflect very well on the
exceptionally safe environment that we
invest in to get performance which is I
think fairly significantly on the bench
okay you've got benchmark internal yeah
which we succeeded in every instance but
where do you get that benchmark figure
from like I just asked that's again a
basketball it's from our oh yeah
treasury management advisors link so
they produce that information thank you
very much
thank you how do we know that it's an
accurate benchmark if they're providing
it and we're measuring at their service
against their benchmark then perhaps the
benchmark might be a little bit low
anyway it's just I'm a bit cynical
sometimes I don't think they've got any
particular interesting sort of skewing I
mean they they operate across that you
know probably half of the local
authorities in them in the country I
don't think they've got any invested
interesting and betraying our speed
position and obviously we employ them as
a professional independent advisors so I
think if we were choose not to accept
their expertise then there's not really
much point of sort of employing them in
the first place it doesn't matter
Adams a money market prime would that be
on deposit for each time what's
everything for that I haven't got the
average length again if you want me to
add that to the table I can add it but
obviously it's in one line of our
treasury management strategy so it will
and depends on the color coding that
each sort of investment is assigned to
by our treasury management risers and
again that and black traits we have to
monitor position on a week-by-week basis
look at the colour coding with science
where do any investment and then make a
little investment decision that's
appropriate to our needs and fits within
our strategy that's why I can tell that
from difficult okay yeah well I can
certainly try and get the average is
that you know I believe we've we had
that money market funds that happened
before the start of the financial year
we did open some money market funds and
sort within the last year or so and our
treasury management strategy says we can
invest up to five million with an
individual
individual funds so yes again we we
device on which which funds met within
our strategy and from our treasury
management visors and yes so we've made
sure that they are I know if I stretch
the recommendation is that is proposed
at the review committee result to
recommend the contents of this trivia
management media report to Council
obviously additionally thank you
[Music]
nothing as the bill failed to pass and
there is no Parliament does not exist
the Olympia will different how to parse
I did look it up I can't see that we can
discuss a bill which doesn't exist in
Coptic list I don't know if he can be
read tradition which I'm sure it could
be but it's got to get another member to
support the bill hesitates on it's
partly nice a bit remote yeah I mean
Francois knows nothing about it that's
not to say that he's not interested in
that he hasn't been approached about it
in any way shape or form
you know the MP that proposed here he's
not standing for reelection so it's a
mess with okay yeah I think that was my
right you know a tool until something is
more concrete or more stable I mean it
was a builder I wasn't I didn't think
about obviously we've seen too
comfortable
collagen is not I've looked into it here
and it done soon interesting and
possibly one that will be great interest
in the future bomb stopping short cannot
propose that we put it on the back
burner all the word painful to locate in
future if that meeting so desires
amongst the many knows is quite a few
here we know to be straight but - it's a
David Amos so I suspect this might I get
the legs in the future but it was
something that should be aware about
okay
we have one item on the key decision
document the same item that's been on
there for the last two months the
brownfield land register okay
next month's meeting there's emergency
planning report probably the only thing
on one of our bank members on is the
working of ropes
in the contract group lucky enough to
obtain the services of rap which is the
waste and resources action program and
they've agreed to do an option to praise
one various options free of charge so
they are going to go away and look at
the various options for the waste
collection and come back to the council
in a roundabout March time at which time
we will prepare a report and bring it
forward to the review committee with the
details of the options and which one
they would recommend
the review committee to recommend it on
to Council there's no clear buying this
is because one of the four members of
work agreement we are think with very
specific disease a quite serious
consultant and provide enormous
circumstances we would pay a pencil
around money to utilize their services
that I believe it's government sponsored
and that's our weekly user lights and
they're completely independent
government sponsored we're fortune up to
take the opportunity we've had the right
people at the right place at right time
and done so let's see Willie where they
come back and they walk as there's
policy will give us an impartial
assessment of of the options and then it
will be down to ask with the information
they supply to make the decision on
which route we want to go it was even
just touching the surface was quite
in-depth was there the number of options
are are quite substantial would help how
we go in the room so perhaps it might be
the best thing to have completely
independent professional body look at it
on our behalf and come back to us with
the top three English doors I'm hearing
like that also they'll they'll have some
information about our effort and their
choices for the waste consultation
that's taken place and is due to come
out towards the end of next year
you know there's various things on this
that influence it
by the other because the government
might tell us that we have to change our
collection service and how it operates
and go for a standardization so that's
that's the current situation on them
questions on that or asking a question
um just take these one um I will just
get the opportunity in March
twittering we've got a constitution up
today I think think perhaps we might be
worth because if we look at that a bit
more closely
once the peer review comes out and sort
of on set of slides if they didn't
attend the initial briefing on another
peer reviews out before Christmas that
might be worthwhile if we maybe if I can
bring that up in January the January
meeting just to go through what that may
or may not say deafening pencil Dean
just because I know we will you said we
might be a light touch thing I think it
would be a bit different and press the
carbon neutral by 2030 on the resolution
that was passed by the by for council I
think it did state that there would be
an they would be reporting back which I
talked to mean that the Republican back
during that during their meetings I
never had one meeting so I would expect
me to report back immediately to the
portfolio holder is that kind of take
place yes the portfolio home didn't come
to the last one they different
the policy has got to be presented to
Council in April come to the resolution
yeah so obviously it's got to come to
even March or April review committee and
we thank you Jim just quickly we'll be
looking at some of the Geminoid to me
emergency planning
does that include IT we're looking at as
well where's our reciprocity um it would
be normally under a separate heading but
if you want it to include I think it's
it actually is very important these days
and I would like to see a report if you
like to see where we are with it should
there be an emergency and I think it's a
good idea to keep keep on top of that as
best we can yeah okay speak to mr. Stacy
thank you very much just some
clarification because the risk of always
says suggestion I'm sorry Mike wasn't
quite clear were you asking for the
Constitution update to go to the seventh
day or the peer review in the peer
review I might not be very honest with
you
yeah with a view but sorry are with a
view to what we're doing in not closing
the peer review might have a big bearing
on an action plan explaining that peer
review in relation to that they don't
follow it Constitution tonight but in
relation to the Constitution I don't
think on the whole is necessarily I
believe they were already making plans
to the office is making plans to
instigate something because of the
comments yeah steve-o chill for solo
fell hold on